teammate most likely to go pro in
another sport probably Jay Rich in
soccer become a social media influencer
probably Tyler hero who has the best
Taste of music I would say myself but I
know Jay Rich he's a DJ and that's kind
of his thing teammate most likely to
answer your phone call if you're in a
pinch Orlando Robinson most likely to be
a standup comedian Kevin Love most
likely to buy a basketball team one day
maybe Kyle most likely to win a dance
off Thomas Bryant you don't got any
moves I mean I can I can bust down most
likely to start a fashion line Tyler
most likely to become a coach after
retiring from playing I'm going to say
Kyle and last one most likely to have a
cameo in a movie me I'm going to be a
movie one day yeah I have a reality show
already what's it called um it doesn't
really have a name yet but you guys can
watch it Triple J reality TV